[Music]
hey it's me
red you know the guy everybody hated who
kind of saved the whole island anyway
war with Leonard in the pigs what are
you gonna do I'm a foodie still going on
those what and BOM and Chuck are doing
whatever they do I eat dirt and me well
I still have some anger issues but I'm
finding healthier ways to deal with it
Fred I know we've had our differences
but we've discovered that there's a
third island maybe one good reason why I
should believe you now show you the
proof real team
really the practices a hundred times
guys this is my sister silver we just
don't think you're gonna be compatible
with the team oh wow it is such a
pleasure to meet not you but you I like
her we gotta get to the island is what
my assistant was going to say
[Music]
this is the amazing team I've been
working around the clock for well that's
disappointing we're break-in and
deactivate the weapon we look amazing we
gotta get that key card oh oh fellow
Eagle God how he's doing a voice yeah
I'm just gonna
[Music]
there goes my toothpaste I am tired of
this go get I'm done living on this
frozen festive we're gonna need a bigger
slingshot
[Music]
[Music]
it's made red welcome back to bird
island not much has changed I'm of
course still a hero and this war with
Leonard in the pigs has no end in sight
these stupid baby
I guess birds and pigs will always be
enemies I know we've had our differences
but we've discovered that there's a
third island in their bodies it destroys
all
is this any part we need to put aside
our differences and work together are
you freaking kidding me
each of you has been selected because
you're the best in your field that we
could find we got to be prepared for
anything is what my assistant was going
to say this is the amazing team I've
been working around the clock for well
that's disappointing what's going on
down there
yeah I'm just gonna
[Music]